hey Jennifer how are you how you doing
Morgan I'm doing great I was just
talking to Bobby and Naomi and they said
that they would hire you as a real
estate agent because they think you can
sell just about anything do you agree
with that
wow what a compliment
um
wow well
God what does that say about me because
then I could sell them something really
terrible and and they'd go for it
um they would
I don't know yeah I mean uh
I don't know I'm fascinated with real
estate I do love like one of my friend a
lot of my friends are real estate agents
I love to go to open houses I love to
look at houses I only have purchased two
in my lifetime but um but the amount of
homes that I've looked at just for I
don't know my fantasy you know I've
looked at thousands thousands have you
watched selling sunset
yes I have I feel like Karen Calhoun
could give any real estate agent on
selling Sunset a run for their money
hey you know some of those some people
end up married to those guys and stuff I
mean like you know you can get like
relationships out of these shows that's
true right I love that that's where your
mind goes
it's true
um you know what's so great about this
show and from talking to the cast
everyone was kept in the dark
essentially you only got a couple of
scripts at a time how much fun was that
for you
I thought it was going to be a bit uh a
huge problem because I thought like why
I I wouldn't know you know
I wouldn't be able to make all these
conclusions about the character and
everything and it actually ended up
being the exact opposite it sort of
uh it was a huge Advantage not knowing
you know you can't really tip off
anything if you don't know
if you're the Watcher or not
you know so you can't so you're just
you're doing it in real time and it's
somehow easier to play
yeah
it's true uh you know if you if you and
your family moved into your dream home
and you have creepy neighbors and you're
getting even creepier letters are you
staying and fighting or are you running
for the Hills
yeah I'm
I'm definitely staying and fighting I
don't like you know there's all these
there's all these stories in the world
how like you know someone moves to a
neighborhood and they want this house
they like the house next door to them
better than their house and then you you
know or you know they hear these stories
of what and people you know not quite
the Watcher story but they'll just make
the people's lives miserable until they
give up their house you hear these dirt
you know where they just sort of
blatantly you know play their music all
day you know and I think that's so
uh unfair and Evil
and so I would stay and fight I would
get you know 15 20 pit bulls I would
have uh I would have my house you know
just jacked with cameras everywhere I
would have my bathroom in my closet like
turned into a safe room
um I I would fight to the death
I'm gonna come live with you or I'm
gonna call you if I ever have a bad
neighbor that's amazing
that's so great
um you and Naomi Watts have such great
scenes together what was it like working
with her
wow she's the coolest she really is
um you know
a lot you know when you're an actor and
you
live in sort of different cities than
another actor and you haven't been on
jobs with them you know you just
all you have is sort of you've been an
observer of their brilliant acting for a
long you know especially her I mean
she's such a brilliant actress and so I
was just a real fan but then I really
got to know her on this job there was a
lot of down time waiting from set up
shots and and um
you know I didn't have an apartment you
know when I got to New York I was came
from LA and
um Naomi helped me get an apartment and
she you know she uh really helped me out
and um
she's
so cool like she's such an amazing
person you know you just don't know
sometimes you think the actors you think
are going to be the most incredible
people in the world that you're you know
you're going to be you show up and they
don't want to speak to you and then you
know you never know but she uh I have to
say like she's like I'm her number one
fan for sure I love hearing that yeah
Martindale
um you know I didn't have many scenes
with Noma but a huge fan of her work
um
and
yeah she's the bomb shot yeah what what
that was a that was a very cool cast to
work with I hope I hope there's another
one
yeah Mia Farrow said the same thing
about you she wishes she had more scenes
with you
okay oh good good I'm good yeah well
thank you so much congrats on the series